hello everyone this game was played in
simultaneous exhibition on 28th of
December in Zagreb in Croatia this was a
two-day event organized by the Kasparov
Adriatic chess foundation the day before
the simultaneous exhibition there was a
youth chess tournament and 120
participants from three countries played
a tournament and the winner of the under
nine-year-old section and the winner of
the under 11 year-old section will have
won a prize to play in the simultaneous
exhibition against the Garry Kasparov
and in the indie exhibition as part of
faiths and Croatian celebrities some top
government people and one of the
participants was Mario coach Mario coach
is a is a successful Croatian theatre
and film director also he enjoys
attending trivia challenges not only as
a player but also as a host I think I
attended at least one trivia challenge
that he was hosting it was very
enjoyable
he's a casual chess player his entire
life and not only that he's also a DJ on
New Year's Eve I attended a party where
he was the DJ here in my hometown and it
was quite a blast so naturally I was
very interested in this game when I
heard he was playing against Garry
Kasparov I asked him if he could send me
the game maybe he recorded it but he
said I will publicly show it on Facebook
as he was he was very proud of playing
Garry Kasparov he's you know a great guy
and a great world champion so this is
the game the beast with a thousand eyes
against the man the man of many talents
and this game is basically a story of
how to play and how not to play against
the London system so let's see this game
Kasparov has the white pieces and he
opens up with d4 we have d5 by Mario
Bishop to f4 Knight to f6 and III kind
of the basic setup of the London system
he six by Mario Bishop to d3 Knight to
c6 we have Knight to f3 Bishop to d6 now
challenging as part of the bishop on f4
and here I've seen players play
something like Bishop to g3 but Kasparov
actually ignores this he plays an IV to
d2
and Mario can double spiral spawns here
by capturing an f4 but he doesn't he
castles black doesn't really gain that
much by doing this if he captures and it
captures on f4 okay you double the white
spawns but now White has insane control
of d5 square and let's say the game
continues for example you Castle c3 will
definitely come by white and after black
continues either but let's say Bishop to
d7 now comes 95 and this Knight is stuck
there in the center you can never
capture there as there is so much
control if you capture then this pawn
chain is is amazing Knight has to go
back and there's simply too much here
for white
so after this Knight B to D to Mario I
think Mario he I mean he could capture
but I think it's best not to capture he
castles and c3 by Kasparov we have rook
to e8 and Knight to e5 now and Bishop to
e7 this Bishop 37 seems like a loss of a
temple maybe maybe maybe there are some
better moves probably something like h6
and then the game continues Queen f3 and
so on but after 95 Mario plays Bishop
back to e7 would the idea he wants to
get rid of the knight on e5 but he
doesn't want to give up the bishop pair
so he wants to capture with the sea
Knight and well this isn't possible if
the bishop is on d6 because after D
captures I need 5 then both Bishop on d6
and knight and f6 will be attacked so
this is him preparing to capture the
night with the c6 Knight Kasparov
continues Queen to f3 we have Knight
captures D captures on e5 and Knight to
d7 and here h6 is played gaining more
control of the g5 squares so no Bishop
to g5 ideas of alleviating the pressure
can be played also he is preparing his
expansion on the King side and of course
attacking the black King capturing the
point of course is impossible if you
capture than simply Bishop captures on
h7 this is winning for white you have to
run away with the King if you capture
then comes Queen Queen h5 checking has
to go back rook captures already or
threatening checkmate so this is
completely winning for white so after h4
my replace
and a sperm goes for Queen to h5 h6 was
played and probably well not probably g6
was definitely a better idea here
kicking the Queen away and this would
hold the position not allowing this
Bishop to exert this immense pressure on
the h7 square but here Mario played h6
and here a lot of moves are possible for
White Knight to f3 rook h3 followed by
rook g3 pressuring the g7 but casparo
goes for the straight forward Bishop
captures on h6 and Mario plays Knight
captures on e5 if you capture G captures
on h6 then after Queen captures on h6
there is a threat of a bishop to h7 and
this will be checkmate Bishop h7
checking h8 then Bishop g6 check this
you all know this checkmate so this
would have to be stopped
something like f5 but now rook to h3
following rogue g3 to follow
we have knife captures on e5 there's
really there's really no better move for
black river and after rook to g3 it's
all over you either have to move the
king then Queen g7 is checkmate or you
have to block with the bishop and give
up the bishop and the Queen for the rook
even if you block with Knight g4 simply
rook captures and after F captures
Bishop to g6 and there is no defense
here whatever black plays simply
checkmate is coming so after this
special characters on h6 Mario doesn't
capture the bishop he plays Knight
captures on e5 and Queen captures on e5
and here the best move for black is to
actually capture just capture the bishop
after G captures on h6 and something
like Queen to h5 Bishop to f8 protecting
the h6 pawn and white is still better
here but maybe black could hold this
well it would definitely be a lot better
than then the move that was played in
the game after Queen captures on e5
Mario decided to go Bishop to f6 kind of
maybe with a temple on the Queen and
only capture the bishop after that but
after Queen to g3 now the pawn is pinned
you cannot capture the bishop and now
it's simply a winning position for white
came to f8 unpinning
now
the g5 better captures h captures we
have g6 Queen to e5 King to e7 rook to
h7 rope to f8 now defending the f7
square and here casparo can capture
immediately on g6 special characters and
g6 as the F pawn is pinned but this is
something as part of says it's when
you're playing in a simultaneous game
and in a simultaneous exhibition and you
have a winning position it's you know
never forget about your own kings safety
so even there's even there's really no
danger here for White Queen to a5
doesn't really pose any threats but it's
you know best the castle as you have a
lot of games going on so he castles
first and Bishop to d7
we have Knight to f3 rook to see it and
only now that he has all of his pieces
are nice squares and now he plays Bishop
captures on g6 rock to g8 and rook
captures on f7 this is with check that
the King has only one square that's game
to e8 and here
Kasparov actually has a checkmate in two
Queen to d6 you can to defend the rook -
FA - checkmate it will be both check
from the rook and from the bishop and g6
but he goes for a different kind of
checkmate he plays rook to g7 this is
checkmate in three King to f8 was played
and now Queen to f4 and here Mario
played Queen to f6 and Queen captures on
f6 this is checkmate it doesn't matter
if you capture the rook simply Queen
goes to f7 King h8 and queen to h7 is
checkmate so definitely an interesting
and instructive game and how how to face
the London system and what what moves to
avoid as there are clearly mistakes but
it's interesting I think it was in this
position after Bishop captures rook
captures and rook to g7 here Queen to f4
I think it was in this position Mario
was actually giving an interview and he
said that while he was waiting for
Kasparov to make his move or maybe it
was in this position not really
sure I was in this inten kasparov old
queen at 4:00 Mario said that yes he
clearly is lost and that everyone can
see this even the news reporter said
that there will be checkmate in three
moves but he said that as far probably
already saw this long ago so yeah that's
the game that's the one game I got from
this simultaneous exhibition if any of
you have any other games from the
simultaneous exhibition feel free to
send them I will gladly show them here
on my channel I would like to thank Nico
and I are calling whale and Zachary
hankins and Mark Hayward for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon